85 missile strikes were fired at Ukraine
at our places of the
highest exchange in terms of energy
infrastructure, which he wants a
ticket from 20 strikes
too I ask you all and be an
hour knowing
our places kept us all visible all
lived Glory to Ukraine
all I was all deep-Budenko not 100
guests, we shot a pan on the table,
but I’m the order
of Ukraine, so I don’t know anything, I
heard I ran here to find out that the
phone was not answering here
Russia
It’s not that it’s not normal, it’s zhah As
they say in Ukrainian language Because
they hate people so much for what they came
here with  Everyone in Belgorod rested in the
beautiful city of Kharkov, remember, you know,
they used to come to us all the time and that
's all I don't know
[music]
It seems to me that there is some kind of
tactic to starve people out and
think that starvation will exhaust
us here I think  nothing will exhaust us we
are strong we are strong and we believe that we
will win
and have long struck we said
our sovereign cordons already on the
territory of M  Moldova And today, Russian
missiles hit Poland on the territory of
our friendly Ukraine, the people of the
Ukrainian brothers skilki looked in Ukraine
spoke of our Ukraine, the power of the terrorist of
surprise Poland, the powers of the bastard
food for the hour of Cola in the Russian
missiles to be missiles on NATO territory, the
Russian missile
shock
essence of the body, the escalate, the diet is required I want
to tell all our Polish brothers
Ukraine of
fork people terror unevil direct
can viciously shaking fear with you and me
not in May